we've all been there we get the great
idea a new project in mind perhaps a new
job opportunity and none of the
questions happen what if I'm not ready
what if I can't do this what if I fail
hello everyone I'm Jesse I'm a
registered nurse and entrepreneur and I
make videos on healthy living and
minimalism in today's video we're going
to talk about how to defeat self-doubt
so that you can be successful whatever
that term means to you so first and
foremost you have to define what success
means to you because it means different
things to different people if you're
gonna work towards a goal but don't know
what that goal is where the final end
result is it's gonna be hard to find
motivation on the way to getting there
and especially when facing difficult
obstacles it is crucial to have a
clearly defined why for what you're
doing what you're doing so the first
thing that I would recommend doing is
take a moment to write down your ideas
for what motivates you is that your
family is that your job is that that you
want to have a greater financial status
what is your reason for why my first tip
is block out the media there's so much
negative information out there about how
horrible the world is and there's so
much good that is happening that you're
not hearing about that negative
information is not gonna help you defeat
self-doubt my second tip for you would
be stay away from toxic relationships
you know those friends the ones that are
always gossiping the ones that you're
not really sure of if they really like
you or not or that you can really trust
they don't exactly motivate you to be a
better person and they're not helping
you to grow either on the other hand tip
number three is find friends that you do
find motivation from people that are
doing things that you want to be doing
or that know the things that you want to
be learning when you find yourself down
or unmotivated these are the people that
are gonna help you get back up on your
feet not the people that are gossiping
or telling you all the ways that it can
go wrong tip number four is constantly
feed yourself with motivation whether
that means prayer for you motivational
YouTube videos podcasts books audio
books the possibilities are endless but
do this often Andrew
keenly tip number five is to journal I
love this one because when I'm angry
when I'm sad when I'm upset for any
reason I can write those things down and
figure out what motivated me to think
that way what made me feel that way by
knowing yourself better you're gonna
know what triggers those negative
thoughts to begin with tip number six is
focus on the positives take time to
write down the things that you are doing
right the things that you're grateful
for by focusing on what is going right
and what you are improving in you will
perhaps see possibilities and
opportunities or perhaps somebody else
will just see risks and along with that
tip number seven is be as specific as
possible with goals don't just wish for
things to happen
make it a plan write it out say I want
to do this by X date when you write it
down you're making yourself accountable
and you're making yourself believe this
is going to happen and this is how I'm
going to do it this next tip I think is
very important in its see failure as an
opportunity for improvement just kind of
adopt that motto because you're going to
make mistakes and if you just dwell on
them instead of learning from them
you're not growing as a person and
you're not gonna get any better and
you're just gonna stay stuck where you
are so when you do make a mistake look
at is a learning opportunity find out
what went wrong and what could I do next
time it's done and it's over with you're
not gonna be able to change the past so
focus on what you can do in the future
this last tip is my favorite by far and
it is take action just do it
there were many occasions in my life
where I questioned myself where I
questioned whether or not my husband and
I could start our own company
successfully where I questioned whether
or not I could be a good nurse where I
questioned whether or not I would be a
good mom the kinds of things that you're
gonna question your self for are gonna
be different but the thing is we all do
these things we're human so just
recognize when they happen and stop them
in their tracks because the truth is
your future is in your hands and you do
have the opportunity to make your life
better I hope you found some of these
tips helpful for you please let me know
which one's your favorite down in the
comments below bye for now
[Music]
hello everyone yes
[Music]